and just like that
and just like that we have the first
footage from the sex and the city
revival and just like that
first the sneak peek features stars
sarah jessica parker cynthia nixon and
kristen davis waving to someone in the
distance the three ladies who play
carrie bradshaw miranda hobbs and
charlotte york to no surprise look as
stylish as ever just trying to give your
money's worth and love is also still
seemingly in the air for carrie and big
there's the fashionista and her husband
played by chris noth kissing and
cuddling in the
kitchen back in july hbo max shared the
first photo from the highly anticipated
revival with the leading ladies and
since filming began the stars of the
series have shared their own
behind-the-scenes glimpses on their
social media accounts including some
on-set photos too including that
intimate carry and big scene in the
teaser do we like it
[Music]
the 10-episode series will follow carrie
miranda and charlotte navigating life
love and friendship in their 50s not
returning however is kim cattrall as
samantha jones after she publicly
declared she was done with the franchise
you are not responsible it probably
wouldn't have worked anyway
i don't think i could feel any worse
meanwhile there are a handful of new
faces joining the cast including sarah
ramirez sarita chowdhury nicole ari
parker and karen pittman e.t spoke with
karen who plays columbia law professor
dr naya wallace and she revealed the
show promises to be very reflective of
the diverse and inclusive nature of new
york city today i love the fact that
this diversity is really being
celebrated it seems in this reboot
because can't say i saw a lot of people
like us
in the original series yeah and i think
what's also great about it is they're
interested in telling full and complete
stories not just about the women who
were on the show but on the women who
are coming into the show and and uh
again long conversations with michael
patrick king and john melfi about it and
you know it's it's super the writer's
room is very diverse i mean it's very
exciting i cannot wait for you guys to
see it
karen also tells et what it was like
filming with the ladies of the og cast
it's exciting it's really great you know
i i was a big fan of sex in the city i
watched it back in the day when it was
on on on television and
you know i know that some of the players
have changed in the story but i will say
what remains
uh in and just like that from sex in the
city is the
story around love and friendship and
womanhood and sisterhood the show really
is a love letter to women in a love
letter to new york city and so
that remains it's so great to be a part
of it i think people will really like dr
naya wallace